you know I have to tell you that when I
was an academic I was a big believer in
the forces of history nothing happens
it's just these these larger dynamics at
play and you know you're at a certain
stage of development that explains why
certain things are possible or not
possible and I must say after I began
working and actually trying to negotiate
I became a much bigger believer that the
forces of personality much more than the
forces of history when you have strong
leaders emerge who are driven by a sense
that they're prepared to achieve big
things or solve conflicts that changes
what's possible at any given moment sure
there's their dynamics created by
technology no doubt about that and the
world is different today than it was and
we have instant communications so we're
in a world that is much more connected
than ever was before and yet you know we
also see very traditional kinds of
conflicts that take place in this
globalized world you look at a place in
the Middle East and we see the most
modern of all places in terms of you
know the instant communication and
transmission of money for investment and
we see people who want to be building
everywhere and we see people who want to
tear down everywhere so these larger
forces are affected by changes in
technology but they're also affected by
individuals and leaders who are prepared
in a sent to take the cudgels and try to
transform reality